[Musica]
ora da quei tempi di passi importanti e
ne sono stati fatti anche l'italia
la legge golfo mosca la cosiddetta
leggete per le pari opportunità ha
offerto sicuramente delle cose
importanti ha offerto la possibilità a
noi donne di poter conquistare delle
posizioni però credo che sia soltanto un
passo non sufficiente per realizzare la
vera differenza la legge sicuramente ci
ha avvantaggiato ma dovremo fare un
passo in più e credere decisamente più
in noi stesse e toglierci questo
cartello del modello donna a tutti i
costi perché poi di fatto dell'epoca
iperconnessa in cui viviamo e dove il
valore
la differenza la fanno i cervelli la
fanno le persone e questi cervelli non
hanno sesso per cui dobbiamo credere più
fortemente in noi stessi e credere nel
valore delle persone
quando qualche anno più avanti 2010
di dar vita
abbiamo proprio quello che abbiamo
realizzato quello che ci sarebbe sempre
piaciuta in qualche modo un posto di
lavoro un po ideale oggi nel 2010 è
quotata in borsa nel 2016 è una piccola
multinazionale abbiamo 140 dipendenti
con un fatturato di circa 60 milioni di
euro presenza in malesia una società e
negli stati uniti una in brasile una in
spagna facciamo applicazioni nel mondo
del digitale ma la cosa interessante è
che abbiamo realizzato
roma in un posto un po come ascoli
piceno ad orvieto con campus un campus
che in ogni luogo per noi ideale per si
ragazzi che lavorano da noi
età media 30 anni
sembrano
conoscenza quello tradizionale del loro
lavoro però hanno una serie di servizi
importanti che rappresentano quello che
era il marzo giorno un miniclub per i
figli dei dipendenti e un servizio non
tutti i servizi gratuiti miniclub
grafici di dipendenti significa che da
noi le donne effettivamente hanno le
stesse opportunità perché
non devono dover scendere tra la
maternità e il lavoro
un sostegno anche dal reale a poter
conciliare la vita i nostri dipendenti
quando sono le tre del pomeriggio è che
non andare a prendere i loro figli a
scuola e di portano da noi fino
all'eolico e le uniche ragazze che sono
importanti sono le due ragazze che segue
dei bambini perché il servizio è solo
mia come dice ma anche della scuola è
chiusa quando a scuola chiusa significa
anche durante l'estate ma in quel caso
il tempo pieno e durante le feste di
natale o quando
teste scolastica sia questo studio sera
nella maggior parte di voi e mamma sa
cosa significa
altre cose importanti che abbiamo fatto
è tutta una serie di servizi sportivi e
palestre
tennis calcetto che staranno
un roseto adesso qualcosa di 20 vero c'è
veramente una rigida detox un centro
estetico unico servizio a pagamento però
è comunque è così come di tipo il
maggiordomo smettono di non perdere
tempo ed è avere la mente più libera
essere più tranquilli
come avete sentito prima sempre con mio
marito lo scorso anno abbiamo dato vita
a una fondazione la fondazione è loro e
katia tomassini abbiamo fatto una scelta
importante noi grazie al digitale
abbiamo avuto la fortuna di divertirci
in un mondo per noi affascinante e
crediamo che sia stata anche quello
strumento che ha permesso di fare la
differenza anche da un punto di vista di
ambito sociale noi veniamo da famiglie
semplici però grazie al digitale siamo
riusciti a trasformare le nostre le
nostre vite
quindi ci sembrava giusto in qualche
modo ridare quello che la scienza
all'innovazione ci ha dato la per
aiutare i nuovi dei ragazzi giovani con
la fondazione facciamo insieme
ovviamente aperta una serie di
iniziative importanti che per noi sono
la aiutare ad arricchire la personalità
dei ragazzi abbiamo una buona biblioteca
e considerate che
e importante sapere dove stiamo noi
stiamo ad orvieto il posto che non è
roma o milano un piccolo centro dove
dovete considerare che non c'è
l'universo cup fino al 2008 ci avevamo
il distaccamento dell'università della
sede di ingegneria di perugia oggi non
c'è più una biblioteca comunale che
aperta nel pomeriggio solo due pomeriggi
a settimana per due ore che vuol dire
praticamente non essere occupata
fermarsi ma non è la stessa cosa che
parla di una grande città quindi noi
abbiamo fatto una scelta risulta
neonatale sui giovani perché i locali
sono effettivamente perrino il nostro
futuro
quindi con la fondazione
facciamo un sacco di promozioni
proponiamo un libro al giorno sui social
ma all'interno della nostra fede
invitiamo esperti a presentare si fanno
concerti musicali si discutono dei temi
di attualità di scienze libri musica di
filosofia per tutto il resto perché da
solo abbia mente la tecnologia non basta
deve essere comunque aiutata da una
visione più ampia di quello che è il
contesto se vogliamo riuscire a
realizzarlo l'episodio e quindi se poi
vi farà piacere insomma vi racconterò
meglio nei dettagli
tutto questo è perché la cosa differente
in questo nostro mondo così l'iter
connesso e proprio avere la possibilità
di dare ai giovani e anche meno giovani
la possibilità di essere di trovare
tutti i giorni una occasione per albera
andare avanti tutto questo adesso tolgo
il video tutto questo è importante per
noi perché offre se guardiamo i numeri
nei numeri importanti un'azienda nel
mondo del digitale con un 47 per cento
di presenza femminile se la paragonate
quelle grandi aziende un grosso
risultato grosso risultato che
considerate il 33 per cento di
all'interno dei quadri dipendenti noi
visto così potremmo starci perché
potrebbe sul risultato ottimo però di
fatto non lo è questo un risultato
ottimo perché all'interno dell'azienda
ci sono sicuramente presenza femminile è
importante ma non c'è la presenza
femminile quindi la solita scende al 13
per cento
nell'ambito più propriamente scientifico
nell'ambito della programmazione le
donne non ci sono questo c'è quindi se
voglio essere felice dico che un'azienda
al 47 per cento femminile ma se la
guardo da un punto di vista della natura
specifica dall'azienda questo risultato
non c'è però non è un risultato soltanto
nostro italiano proprio di questi giorni
apple
ho visto aperto una scuola ovviamente
negli stati uniti per facilitare le
donne che volessero approfondire
l'ambito scientifico perché questa
esigenza
probabilmente in tutte le parti del
mondo non abbiamo ancora fatto il salto
e non ci siamo ancora padroni li di
quelle che sono quelle competenze
specifiche tecnologiche
questo vale degli stati uniti ma vale
anche in europa se andiamo a vedere
probabilmente i paesi che sono più
all'avanguardia sono pochi quelli che
hanno una pro sono quelli più forti dove
hanno una presenza femminile in campi
economici o politici
questo probabilmente è dovuto a tutta
una serie di cose che da solo le leggi
non possono fare
sicuramente tutti voi se immaginate le
scimmie le favole che abbiamo solo
ascoltato sin da piccole
i modelli sono sempre questi modelli di
una donna all'interno di una casa
all'interno di un castello all'interno
delle mura e l'uomo sempre in un ambito
aperto coraggioso sempre forte quindi il
modello era soci terentola biancaneve io
probabilmente come voi se siete qui
avevo altri modelli una ricerca di una
alice nel paese delle meraviglie o una
più feroce o curiosa pippi calzelunghe
piccole cose però queste sono poi quelle
che determinano i russi i risultati
all'interno di un contesto più grande e
su questi probabilmente dobbiamo
continuare a lavorare perché se le donne
riescono a uscire da questi mura
se escono riuscite a queste case
lavorando io sono convinta mi sono fatta
questa idea che soltanto entrando nel
mondo del lavoro per ogni donna che
nucleo famigliare che lavora significa
poter potenzialmente ovviamente avere
una famiglia con un reddito maggiore e
quindi avere maggior maggiori
possibilità di soddisfazione ovviamente
il mondo in cui stiamo vivendo offre
delle possibilità incredibili ci sono i
pessimisti e ci sono certamente gli
ottimisti molte molte di queste
difficoltà che veniamo che ci troviamo a
trovare sentiamo sempre raccontare di
giovani che probabilmente vivono su
tutto il tempo attaccato a un telefono
giovani che
ormai una generazione che non ha più
possibilità io non la vedo così
sicuramente l'innovazione tecnologica da
sola non sa non renderà stupidi questi
ragazzi assolutamente ma invece sono
convinta che offrirà a tutti i nostri
giovani la possibilità di gratuitamente
perché questa il salto importante
rispetto alla nostra generazione
quindi dipende molto solo dalla volontà
i nostri giovani possono se vogliono
imparare una lingua viaggiare e
conoscere cose che nella nostra
generazione non c'era quindi non saranno
più stupidi perché sono davanti a un
computer o un telefonino ma è proprio lì
che potranno invece a fermarsi così come
in un posto più piccolo lontano da un
rene
l'innovazione tecnologica da sola non è
quella che inquina non è quella che
nasconde l'immondizia nei posti
impossibili ma è quella invece che rende
più liberi voglio raccontare un esempio
che forse avete visto prima
nel video nella nostro campus abbiamo
una parabola termodinamica più o meno un
disco ne che forse avete visto prima
non è un radar ma è una parabola che
insegue il sole comunque la parabola noi
facciamo 3600 litri di acqua calda al
giorno quando abbiamo aperto la
palazzina abbiamo più o meno impiegato
nove mesi per costruirla abbiamo dovuto
aspettare dal momento in cui siamo
entrati a viverla nove mesi per avere
l'allaccio con il distributore del gas
quello pubblico nove mesi noi e senza
dover chiedere favori a nessuno con
quella parabola abbiamo avuto l'acqua
calda sempre quindi in ufficio abbiamo
anche voluto farle docce tranquillamente
quindi è un'innovazione che se ben
direzionata può rendere più liberi da
tante difficoltà e storture è
un'innovazione che non li uccidere donne
noi oggi siamo abituati a sentire solo
storie impossibili di uomini che
uccidono fidanzate non è così e
l'innovazione tecnologica offre a queste
donne a tutte noi la possibilità di
affermarci qualche modo di essere più
libere libere e poter lavorare in un
mondo e quindi vivere effettivamente le
pari opportunità
io la vedo un po così
questo è il messaggio che ora lasciare
innovazione tecnologica da solo
ovviamente non fa la differenza ma un
innovazione insieme a uno scambio una
condivisione di cultura sono una
migliore garanzia di prosperità e
progresso sociale manico grazie
[Applauso]